is another issue now at new video
showing a massive migrant caravan
heading north from central america for
the u.s border mexican officials
apparently doing little to prevent it
from reaching our country griff jenkins
traveling in mexico's southern border
with guatemala today griff where are you
what's happening
bill good morning i am in the middle of
the succiate river on one side is
takunamon guatemala on the other side
ciudad hidalgo mexico and this crossing
right here is called the paso del coyote
it's an illegal passing the legal way is
that international bridge in the
distance this way is the illegal way for
30 pesos which is a dollar fifty anybody
can cross there are no immigration
officials of mexico on that side
although when you go a little bit
further off the bank you see them but
little is being done to enforce the
illegal crossings officials locally say
that as many as 800 haitians a day are
now crossing yesterday mexico's uh
foreign minister marcelo ebrard
addressed the mexican senate saying that
they are going to embrace the haitians
seeking refuge that they will get
refugee status and that is why so many
are coming if you just look up the river
for a second bill you can see all of the
crossings happening all day long every
day 24 hours a day now we also ran into
at the refugee center yesterday a
immigrant rights activist out of the u.s
named ireno mujica he is the director of
pueblo san francis organized those
caravans of 2019 that stormed across
that bridge behind me he is down here
blasting the biden administration for
their handling of the crisis here's what
he said
i i will have the violent administration
be responsible with their actions if
they're going to talk nice to the
migrants or they actually say and mean
what they're going to do
not
fill them with hope
and then
build them with pain after they go
deported back
unclear bill whether or not the bind
administration is doing anything now to
prepare for that 15 000 strong caravan
that will come right through here and
we're watching this sir are you and
points for creativity griff well done
we'll track that caravan